What happened to the only Japanese passenger on the Titanic?
Masabumi Hosono was the only Japanese passenger on the RMS Titanic.
As a civil servant working for the Japanese Ministry of Transport,...
...he researched Imperial Russia's railway system in 1910.
His journey back to Japan then took him to Britain.
After staying in London for a time, he went to South Hampton,...
...where he boarded the RMS Titanic on April 10th 1912 in second class.
During the disaster, as the ship was sinking after hitting an iceberg,...
...passengers began boarding the few lifeboats to evacuate.
Hosono was asleep when the crash happened,...
...but awoke when a Stewardess knocked on his cabin and told him to put on a life jacket.
When he tried to go to the top deck where the lifeboats were,...
...he was blocked by a crewman, who assumed he was a third class passenger.
But eventually he slipped passed and reached the top deck.
All the while flares were signaling emergency were being shot into the air ceaselessly,...
...and hideous blue flashes and noises were simply terrifying.
"Somehow I could in no way dispel the feeling of utter dread and desolation," Hosono wrote.
He found a lifeboat, when an officer shouted, "Room for two more!"
And survived the Titanic disaster.